[Musique]
je te pose la question où est passée ma
chemise je suis pressé je t'ai dit que
je parte ya une réunion ce matin il ya
des embouteillages il faut que je parte
tout de suite
alors si j'ai pas de chemise propre je
peux pas les mères réunion je baille à
l'angoissé par yasmina chemise je ne
prends pas que tu viennes me parler à
moi de téchiné ça me fallait vraiment
quelque chose de complètement surréel ça
c'est pas surréaliste lui tombe enfin je
te parle de quelque chose de
d'élémentaire je crois que si l'élément
et d'un travail et il faut quand même
que j'ai une chemise un match en occupe
de ta chemise enfin les coups droits
certains cas les enfants placard à
recommencer les discussions abbas a
annulé ma discussion aux commandes qu'il
sera de toute façon en permanence à
recommencer tant qu'elle sera pas revenu
bon alors il faut que je vais mettre la
chemise que j'avais des galères et je
vais arriver comme un dégueulasse à mon
travail et on me jugera et on dira avoir
alors on dira oui duraquois monsieur y
sol donc c'est parce que madame est sale
c'est pas ça du tout c'est que la vie
des rames et là un petit message d parce
que c'est de ma faute à moi dans l'étude
one drop cette époque là moi je reviens
chaussée tonia loin de la moindre des
choses est au moins de me préparer une
chemise quand je parle pas c'est la
moindre des changes a pas de chômer
jamais toi de toute façon comment tu
fais on s'est marié tu avais 36 ans
oui on l'a fait jusqu'à 36 ans pour tes
cheveux mais j'avais ma mère qui
s'occupe et il a passé sa vie à
exploiter les femmes ou les âneries que
j'ai au moins leurs femmes s'occupent de
leurs monnaies en quoi les hommes et les
femmes travaillent dehors ils
travaillent dedans qu'ils partagent le
travail à l'extérieur qui est un travail
en loyer et reconnu tu m'écoutes l'image
ah bah oui je veux changer les moeurs et
je suis pas la seule à vouloir changer
les moeurs les moeurs ne change pas avec
des lois sociales les moeurs jeunes en
charge avec quoi est un changement des
mentalités mais pour que les mentalités
changent il faut aussi qu'il ya un
changement de loi
enfin toujours est il que je n'ai pas ma
chemise alors tout je me relève moins
chez je ne vais pas travailler et tu
travailles à ma place ou alors qu'il
trouve une chemise comme y avait
toujours énormément de travail à faire
dans un mail
j'avais des enfants des petits-enfants
et pas beaucoup de confort j'avais
l'impression que je n'ai jamais arriver
à faire ma tâche enfin j'étais jamais
arrivé au bout et quand il rentrait je
me sentais très coupable parce que
j'avais souvent pas fini ce que j'avais
à faire
il restait des choses à faire et il
avait toujours un et très creux pour
tomber juste sur la chose qu'il fallait
pas voir et je ressentais ça un peu
comme un rapport de le yak le mot patron
qui me convient comme si j'avais à lui
rendre des comptes sur mon travail
vous n'etes elle était un peu à mon
service
quand j'arrive vous ne lui demandez pas
mal de vous aider non aucune tâche je
crois qu'à l'époque justement jeu ça
faisait partie de mon travail de faire
tout ça et de faire que quand il
rentrait il puisse se détendre et mais
vous monsieur quel était votre travail
bon je je je travaillais des activités
sociales où j'ai exercé des activités
syndicales aussi j'avais peut-être aussi
l'impression que je faisais quelque
chose d'utile réflexion si ça devait
être utile quand même
enfin peut-être vraisemblablement moins
que ce que je crois actuellement dix
activités là est-ce que vous en parliez
avec votre femme est ce que vous essayez
de les lui faire partager
est-ce que ça va être constatée lorsque
vous jouez l'extérieur un peu mon
appareil comme seul soir mais c'était
vraiment une conversation incidente
c'est un beau tellement c'était pas un
partage votre vie active tant qu'elle
était plutôt dehors vous avez le
sentiment d'être tout à fait avec stoner
j'avais un sentiment de solitude d'être
complètement à côté du monde du travail
tout en faisant beaucoup de travail mais
aussi peut-être avec dans le fond d'être
toujours avec des enfants vous êtes
protégé aussi tout d'un coup c'est
maintenant que j'en prends conscience en
parlant comme ça j'étais à la fois
enfin bon un statut inférieur et en même
temps j'avais des privilèges
qu'est ce que vous faisiez leur ensemble
de choses je sais pas si c'était on a de
la peine maintenant à concevoir cette
fin je me demande je sais pas si c'était
peut-être tu pourras la coutume ou ceux
qui existaient à l'époque et c'est ramon
avait plutôt l'impression enfin
maintenant je reconnais qu'on vivait
plutôt à la côte et de look plutôt
convaincu
oui
bon tu me fasses ton chez qui j'ai fini
pointe est le mien je dépasse t ouais
bah ça comme d'habitude comme d'habitude
tu as dépassé de combien tu as posé à
temps où tout était arrêtée là où os ou
total noir à bali dans déjà le 15 avait
dépassé moi je comprends pas comment tu
te débrouilles vraiment de comprendre
moi j'y arrive pas comme ça il arrive
que fait plein de dépenses - qui comme
outil utile t-shirt utile fleurs 345
francs chaussures les boutiques
c'était qu'à regarder à droite à gauche
l'autre sur les robes c'est oui moi je
n'achète pas tous les jours parce que
t'es pas content quand tu me vois bien
bien avisé c'est pas un problème et pas
le problème d'être bien habillé d'être
partout sans le problème c'est ne pas
dépenser plus que ce qu'on gagne
moi quand j'étais plus jeune je gagnais
moi je m'en sortais bien là et comment
t'es tu débrouiller je me débrouillais
t'avais pas de loyer tu étais chez papa
maman tu avais été officiellement qu'il
devait inviter des jeunes etc
alors c'était de l'argent de poche
c'est drôle à chaque fois que je te
donne mon chéquier j'ai l'impression
d'être avec mes parents en train de
redonner mon carnet note
c'est exactement la même chose quand
j'étais jeune je te dise ou encore que
je fasse virer du compte d'épargné sur
le groupe de cheikhs parce que
non si t'as pas une certaine somme
d'argent son chéquier savent à quoi je
me plais le travail que vous faites à la
maison
bah je trouve pas ça très enrichissant
ça va un moment mais moi j'aime pas trop
pas si j'aime bien m'occuper de ma
maison j'aime bien ma maison je j'aime 4
soit agréable et et
j'aime la rangée j'aime la décorer
j'aime qu'elle soit propre et surtout à
mon tour communication dans la journée
c'est la solitude finalement donc il ya
un problème je crois de rester seule
frappe le scot dominique rentrer qu'est
ce que tu as fait aujourd'hui bon je dis
rien parce que ça j'ai pas envie de lui
dire bon moi j'ai repassé où j'ai lavé
je sais pas trois bricoles sait ce
qu'est ce que vous pensez monsieur quand
elle vous dit rien bah ça m'énerve un
petit peu parce que moi j'aimerais bien
qu'elle me raconte un peu ce qu'elle a
fait et elle a l'impression que ça ne
m'atteint mois ont comme j'ai vu
personne dans la journée
j'ai envie de lui parler j'ai envie de
lui redonner les enfants géant j'ai
envie de moi par contre dépit du oui
alors souvent il ya des heures parce que
il a l'impression que la grèce
moi j'ai l'impression que dès que j'ai
mis la clé dans la serrure toc
on colle les deux enfants alors que
j'aimerais bien reprendre un peu mon
souffle mon mal
m'asseoir dans le fauteuil lire lire le
journal
ne serait-ce qu'un quart d'heure pour
faire un petit break
j'avais envie de parler à ce moment là
mais est ce que vous aimeriez vous
occuper davantage de vos enfants le
petit pas encore non c'est difficile
était enfin tu aimes pas ça parce qu'il
faut que ça reste quand même dans des
limites à cette courte attente laisse
moi un petit peu il faut que ça il faut
pas que ça dépasse un certain laps de
temps je pourrai pas toute la journée au
bout de au bout de deux heures ça
devient fatiguant non tu aimes passat
occuper des enfants non adhérents aussi
parce que moi je me souviens au début
comme christophe est arrivé un peu pour
faire faire quelque chose jamais parlé
ou jamais parce que je pense que oui je
sais quoi stresser plus à la mais là je
pense que c'est plus à la mère de
s'occuper de son enfant de le changer de
la v2 et c'est que le père moi j'ai
l'impression de le faire mal de tous
c'est uniquement pour ceux que ça
intéresse du chômage
oui j'avoue que ça me laisse dire
combien de fois tu m'as dira ça
m'intéresse pas alors je veux pas savoir
monsieur qu'est ce qui vous semble
insupportable chez votre femme
aujourd'hui ce qui est insupportable si
je voulais c'est sa mauvaise foi parce
que je crois qu'elles devront en faire
un petit peu plus à la maison elle fait
pas grand chose dans ce cas sa peinture
et elles ne pensent qu à militer à
choisir et dans des mouvements
féministes en ce moment elle s'occupe de
sylvie je feins enfin il pense de tout
les pense à toutes sortes de choses et
en dernier et elle prend elle pense
surtout à gaston à bébert à bricoleur
jeumont mes deux chats et mon chien
avant son mari parce qu'elle dit que je
peux me débrouiller tout seul mais
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez qu'elle
fasse à la maison alors comment est ce
que j'aimerais qu'elle fasse tout ce que
je ne peux pas faire tout ce que je ne
peux pas faire c'est à dire quand je
rentre le soir
j'aimerais avoir au moins l'europa
qu'ils soient prêts or c'est jamais le
cas c'est souvent moi qui fait leur part
marc elle fait la vaisselle après
conférence partage exactement toutes les
tâches mais j'ai l'impression que j'en
fais à 75% et à la 25 % alors comme elle
milite dans un mouvement féministe
vous laissez les rôles renversé
maintenant ça va bientôt être les hommes
qui vont aller qui vont s'occuper des
enfants et qui vont rester à la maison
et les femmes qui vont prendre des
responsabilités travailler à l'extérieur
ce qui me gêne c'est ce qui me gêne et
vous madame vous pensez qu'ils partagent
réellement les tâches domestiques non
pas du tout pour effectivement il fait
souvent la cuisine mettaient d'accord au
départ quand on s'est mariés que moi je
ne ferai pas la cuisine
il m'a dit je te promets on en parlera
jamais de cette histoire de cuisine on
peut se marier autrement j'étais bon
très bien on va essayer et depuis cinq
ans je n'entend parler que de cuisine
bon mais alors on tue traduisez suis
travail met à l'aise parce qu'ils
travaillent je me laisse parler je t'ai
laissé parler d'une au travail passe par
le travail
en ce qui concerne les tâches
domestiques leurs rondeurs de cette
cuisine jeux tu ne fais rien je pars du
principe qu'on peut s'occuper de chacun
d'eux sa petite merde on est tous
capables de se préparer son petit jaune
et de l'avc bol de se laver son linge de
ce coût de ces boutons de faire tout ça
ce que j'ai fait moi jamais jamais il ne
me serait venu à l'idée d'avoir une
femme de ménage on est marqué une
existence de bourgeois pas du tout j'ai
absolument connu une existence
bon je fais de la désole tu as ta
voiture tu es une femme de ménage qui
promène son chien tu vas voir des
copines et humilité si je ne vois je ne
suis pas venu je demande en quoi tu mets
la tête
[Musique]
mais est-ce que c'est dur le travail que
vous faites monsieur oui c'est dur parce
que je suis dans les embouteillages
toute la journée je fais exactement le
boulot d'un presque d'un chauffeur de
taxi et en plus je dois m'arrêter voire
du client le client n'est pas là je dois
revenir et finalement ça devrait se
concrétiser à la fin de la journée par
un certain nombre de commandes et si je
n'ai pas ce certain nombre de commandes
à la fin de la journée je suis sur les
nerfs parce que parce que c'est comme ça
mais quand tu arrives oui le soir tu ne
fais rien tut allonge il faut d'abord
que j'écoute ton discours parce qu'en
général c'est crever alors je fais
d'abord la petite infirmière
ensuite je tut tut tut allonge tu
t'attends vraiment à ce que je te
prennent en charge totalement manqués -
j'ai déjà souvent une journée difficile
tu sais faire un tableau 1 on le sait
qu'un travail de création c'est pas
évident c'est très fatigant c'est moi
également arica casquette mais toujours
avec toi plus ou moins fatiguant j'ai
fait j'ai fait le travail que tu as fait
j'ai fait le même mais moi je suis
obligé de leur chef ben ali tandis que
toi tu te reposes complètement sur moi
qui suis qui fait son a aussi j'ai
travaillé pour gagner ma vie
bien que le soir je m'occupais de mon
ménage je m'occupais de mes affaires est
encore très serré en plus je faisais du
sport en plus je sortais excuses avait
besoin d'un second salaire oui en plus
qui plus est alors c'est pour ça que je
vais travailler à la rentrée et j'aurais
et non je vais vous lire on vit au
dessus de nos moyens
ah oui on vit de houston donnant comme
toujours les gens qui nous perd ça l'est
on aurait une vie normale on aurait pas
de maison de campagne je crois qu'on
pourrait très bien vivre avec ce que je
gagne mais on a une maison de campagne
et puis on a deux chats ça coûte très
cher un chien ça coûte très cher si on
avait des enfants
quand je vais acheter du boeuf
bourguignon pour le chien venez pas fini
on coupe et non le report
non vous ne voulez pas moi je veux moi à
lui moi je comprends cela j'en voulais à
son père depuis depuis le temps que je
lui demande de faire un enfant ne veut
pas alors je reconnais un fauconnier
jeux wii jory parce que bon pas compte
tenu des des choses actuellement ce sera
encore moi qui devrais m'occuper de
l'enfant à 100% c'est évidemment pas
envisageable ni pour l'enfant ni pour
moi mais est ce que vous aimeriez vous
occupez de l'enfant bien sûr j'aimerais
beaucoup je serais ravi von hartz iv en
vain puisque tu n'aimes pas la même
tasse à 7 h mis dans la mesure de leurs
possibilités évidemment si je suis chez
des clients je ne peux pas moins grimpé
mais pourquoi vous ne voulez pas
d'enfant je n'ai jamais voulu d'enfant
quand j'ai vu qu'il pourrait être
aussi dans une société future et que
certains couples vives à aujourd'hui
oui lieu cette interchangeabilité total
mais tu sais mais la formule amusante le
fauteuil comme des dingues hommes et
femmes alors oui c'est exactement mais
il allait bien dans les pays occidentaux
ils ne veulent pas d'un échangeur soir
elle méprise les choses et met toute
façon tant que femme je n'ai rien à dire
il sait mieux estime alors mais je
réponds à des arguments et tu réponds
rien tu me laisses pas terminée parce qu
est ce que je vais dire quand on écoute
moi j'avais tu termines pour moi parce
que tu sais exactement ce que j'ai à non
je ne dis plus rien moi tu sais bon j'ai
commencé à me poser des questions et je
dois dire que si j'avais 20 ans
aujourd'hui
ou si vraiment tandis que j'ai 34 ans il
arrivait quelque chose comme ça très
vite maintenant dans ma vie je crois que
c'est possible d'avoir un enfant quand
on peut partager avec un homme quand un
couple devient un véritable couple c'est
jeu je pensais que c'était possible de
vivre en couple tout en partageant
vraiment les choses
de toute manière je crois encore que
c'est possible est-ce que vous avez ce
supporter cela longtemps alors on enfin
c'est devenu petit à petit tout à fait
insupportable
la solitude
chaque fois que je parlais j'avais
l'impression que la parole ne voulait
rien dire enfin que c'était un
signifiant parce que finalement les
enfants allez tous au lycée et puis mon
mari a eu l'occasion de reprendre des
études supérieures en 35 ans et jeu mais
surtout et à la maison avec quatre
intellectuels si on peut dire des gens
qui étudiait et donc chaque fois que je
parlais j'avais l'impression que ce que
je disais était sans importance parce
que je n'avais pas justement une
référence à une culture
je ne savais pas toujours exprimer les
choses comme on devait d exprimer je
n'avais pas de source
comme eux enfin je me sentais
complètement à côté
comment est ce que vous avez pris
conscience qu'il fallait que ça change
alors comment ça vous est venue cette
idée là un petit peu par hasard enfin je
pense que une ou deux de mes amis ont vu
que j'étais pas très bien et peut-être
éprouvé aussi un petit peu la même chose
et elles m'ont invité à des réunions
avec un groupe de femmes ont servi une
fois par mois pour discuter un petit peu
nous nos problèmes afin d' enfant de vie
c'est là que j'ai justement eu enfin
rencontré des femmes qui s'organisent
autrement que moi et dont les relations
de couple était différente et par
exemple je me souviens dans les
premières réunions avoir été très étonné
quand l'une a dit mais moi le jeudi le
jour de congé des enfants je ne me lève
que huit heures et ça m'a ouvert des
horizons illimités c'est à dire que je
me suis dit mais après tout je suis bien
bête pourquoi je le fais pas parce que
jusqu'à maintenant je trouvais naturel
de me lever le jeudi comme les autres
jours à 7 heures du matin parce que je
faisais le café mon mari et vous
monsieur quand vous avez vu que ça
bougeait un peu du côté de votre femme
quelle tête vous allez faire une sale
tête parce que bon disons que j'ai
jamais vraiment cru que je sais pas tant
que temps que j'ai cru que c'était au
niveau de la conversation fallait
réunion autour d'une tasse de thé je
sais même pas si j'ai vraiment que ça
s'était toujours une réunion facile
c'était toujours des réunions autour
d'une tasse de thé j'ai senti tout de
suite que c'était beaucoup plus grave
que ça que ma femme était reprend de
m'échapper de quelle façon une autre
fois quand je dis m'échapper s'était pas
c'est pas au sens politique du terme
c'est à dire que l était en train de
s'écarter de son côté comme peut-être
moi je m'étais écarté du bien que
finalement ils se trouvaient tous les
deux sur la touche
non seulement elle remettait en cause ce
qui les bases du coup c'est que en même
temps à se demander comment elle avait
pu supporter ce qui existait avant
c'était beaucoup plus grave que ce que
de remettre simplement en cause et de
changer c'était de se dire mais pourquoi
est ce qu'on a vécu comme ça jusqu'à
présent c'était assez grave c'est une
remise en cause complète du groupe
alors comment vous avez vécu tous les
deux ensemble ces moments là j'ai
manière assez violente
vraiment c'était pas agréable du tout je
crois que ce qui est très discret très
dur là dedans c'est que celui contre
lequel il faut lutter on l'aiment aussi
donc c'est une lutte commune luttes
syndicales sauf que vous aimez votre
patron quoi alors ça s'est passé comment
alors
olala ça s'est passé très mal c'était
très douloureux très dur beaucoup de
disputes
[Musique]
madame votre mari votre tard le soir il
a l'air assez assez occupé vous ne
voulez pas beaucoup enfin pas très
longtemps pour vous est-ce que vous
souhaiteriez qu'il est davantage de
temps libre
bah disons que c'est difficile qu'ils
aient davantage de temps libre puisqu'il
a une profession qu'il prend beaucoup
mais enfin voir finalement si j'avais un
petit peu plus de temps libre le post
répète voilà mesdames avec moi tu
risques faniel je suis par exemple si je
pouvais sortir à 4h ou 5h la vie ne me
lit j'irai faire un petit tennis mais je
vais vous arrive par exemple de sortir
le soir chacun de votre côté dominique
temps en temps une une fois tous les 36
du mois j'essaye de garder le contact
avec deux ou trois mes anciens amis et à
ce moment là on mais c'est quoi une fois
ou deux mais parce que je rouspète parce
que j'aime pas non ça respire même
minute parce que sinon tu dis au débat
je les verrais bien une fois par semaine
une fois par semaine par exemple à un
ami que tu vois qui est marié donc on
pourrait très bien se voir 1,4 mais tu
me diras ce cas c'est pas pareil on
discute pas de la même chose on n'a pas
les mêmes quand on est deux célibataires
enfin quand on est deux tous les deux
sur les femmes on a plus de sujets de
discussion que le quand les femmes sont
là enfin moi je trouve ça ridicule c'est
quand on sort à deux ou à trois
c'est pas la même ambiance au retrouve
un peu cette liberté bon c'est pendant
que je le fais miss à la maison en train
de garder les enfants
ah ça c'est ça que je mets un passage
avoue que ça me manque un petit peu et
je le fais une fois une fois tous les
tous les mois ou tous les deux mois même
pas mais vous pour répondre sentez vous
par le soir avec des amis alors voilà
c'est pas parce que
que toutes ses amies sont mariés misant
mari voilà moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui
sont mariés
ne sort pas elle sans leur leur mari mon
choix je crois que tu apprécies ray pas
tellement si je te disais allez chérie
tu t'occupes des enfants et moi je vais
faire la petite la petite jeune fille
avec avec une amie impact apprécierait
que je rentre à 3 heures du matin alors
que l'expérience je pense que tu me dis
mais ça ne lui arrive de rentrer à 3
heures mais leur taille d'une boîte à
nourrir entre à 3 heures du matin qu'est
ce que vous faites à ces cas là moi je
suis sans dormir parce que je suis
énervée elle a regardé l'heure et moi
j'ai regardé l'heure avant jeudi jusqu'à
quelle heure tu es rentré il mardi
toujours sur leur mais moi je sais à
l'heure à laquelle il est rentré parce
que je me réveille toujours à vendre
enfin je dois vous n'osez pas lui dire
l'heure à laquelle vous rappelle bon je
vous ai des gamines non non non je mets
toute façon je vous dise et c'est
vraiment très très fort et oui c'est
malheureusement monsieur vous avez quand
même des moments de détente le tennis
n'était la chasse l'hiver ça va assez
bien pour vous quand est ce qu'elle se
détend voterai jamais la charge vous
citez la chasse bon j'aime bien la
chasse je vais à la chasse à peu près un
dimanche sur deux pendant la saison j'ai
proposé à claire de m'accompagner à la
chasse mais ça ne m'intéresse pas
spécialement
alors que je pensais qu'une balade dans
les ca m'interesse pas mais qu'est ce
que tu fais des enfants on peut les
laisser à la bruyère ça c'est son grand
mot on peut les laisser on peut les
laisser enfin moi je suis pas d'accord
que ben alors moralité je vais
effectivement je la plupart du temps je
m'en vais seul mais si vous vouliez pas
des activités personnelles l'après midi
vous pourriez pas de donner vos enfants
à garder c'est à dire moi j'aime pas
trop parce que étant donné que
que je travaille pas donner mes enfants
à garder moi ça j'ai un petit j'ai un
sentiment de culpabilité de ne pas
m'occuper de mes enfants étant donné que
j' ai rien à faire d'autre que de
m'occuper de mes enfants et ça m'embête
un peu de l'effet regardé par gêne pas
j'ai l'impression de les priver de
quelque chose d'eux en les laissant à
quelqu'un d'autre chez pas penser aussi
que c'est votre rôle dans donc c'est mon
rôle oui c'est mon rôle de l'éducation
qu'on m'a donnée qui qui qui me fait
penser que c'est mon rôle
dans ces temps rôle mais ça peut être un
rôle qui de temps en temps permet
d'isoler serait pour aller travailler
que je laisserai mes enfants à une
personne ou à la crèche n'importe quoi
bon je n'aurais pas le même sentiment
mais pour aller me distraire
la vie n'a pas l'air d'être toujours
facile entre vous quel serait votre
votre homme idéal madame j'aimerais bien
un homme en fait qui ce qu'ils soient
capables de faire un vrai chemin et se
remettre en question toute façon pas un
homme voulant travailler comme une brute
uniquement pour gagner de l'argent pour
des choses comme ça j'aimerais bien un
homme qui soit assez un homme
d'intérieur lorsqu'était ses muses ans
et que je dise un jour une amie qui me
dit ah bon un homosexuel alors parce que
pour la plupart des gens un homme qui
aimerait mettre des fleurs dans un vase
ou faire ou à améliorer son intérieur ça
forcément un homosexuel
j'aimerais un homme en fait qu'on n'est
pas un être qui me seraient
complémentaires qu'on cherche tous les
deux il est pas que soit votre mari
c'est à dire qu'il a des idées
malheureusement tout fait comme beaucoup
de gens est très stéréotypé et qu'il ya
toujours des rôles avec lui mais enfin
il
j'espère qu'avec le temps il et vous
monsieur qu'est ce qu'on pensait ce
qu'elle dit bah écoutez moi la femme
idéale je vais vous dire une chose
hormis les questions domestiques
c'est ma femme je suis très amoureux
d'elle et finalement toutes ces
questions si vous voulez sont tout à
fait insignifiante par rapport si vous
voulez à mettre en garde à vous prendre
beaucoup de temps mais oui ça me prend
ça nous prend beaucoup de temps parce
que s'ils voulaient en fait c'est ce qui
détruit le quotidien les histoires de
l'histoire de cuisine c'est ce qui
détruit l'amour c'est dommage
ouais moi je pourrais dire la même chose
tu pourrais être un homme idéal s'il
avait pas tout ça mais tout ça crée
souvent des tensions qui font qu'en tout
cas le couple n'est plus aussi bon qu'il
devra être 10 ans ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on en arrive quand même à un dialogue
parce qu'il ya tellement de gens qui
sont stéréotypés dans un sens stéréotypé
dans l'autre et qui finalement
d'ailleurs arrivé divorce et que je me
demande s'il sait pas plus positif qu
autre chose avec que ça débouche quand
même sa vie alors que la vidange à 11
c'est fatigant c'est fatigant et
finalement c'est une énergie qui qui est
perdu et qui est un petit peu dommage
s'en remet en question ça le remet
totalement en question et je reconnais
que c'est difficile pour lui
peut-être plus difficile que pour moi
c'est plus difficile
de quitter son trône que de quitter le
bar agne c'est bien évident mais je
crois que c'est là que les hommes se
trouvent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]